[Music]
i'm rj i'm one half of wd detailing and
today we're going to be showing you how
we clean quite possibly the muddiest ws6
firebird ever it was involved in a
really bad flood in kentucky the car was
absolutely covered basically head to toe
in caked on mud to the point to where
the mud had dried and it was starting to
crack almost like a desert floor
i can only assume that it was involved
in very fast moving water it picked up
sediment from somewhere nearby and then
it dried out
so the first step is removing pretty
much anything except for the dashboard
and the steering wheel in the steering
column because that was a little bit
more involved than we really had time
for
using the vacuum to remove any residual
water from the back of the trunk
going into the detail i knew a lot of
this vehicle was going to be sold for
parts because there was only x amount
made and only a certain amount of parts
available it wouldn't make sense to
scrap that car especially with so many
parts still being functional to change
some of the ways that we were going to
be cleaning the vehicle and using some
methods that we wouldn't use in a normal
detail and we've never done this before
but we literally took a pressure washer
and sprayed out the whole interior of
the vehicle in order to remove all the
mud so the reason why we wouldn't do
that in a normal detail job is it would
definitely damage some of the electrical
components of the vehicle if you didn't
give the car ample time to dry so if
this was a normal vehicle that we did
that in we would have to disconnect the
battery and then make sure that it dried
out for over five or six days
with a car in this condition to clean
the carpet was again different than most
vehicles that we see on a daily basis so
we probably spent about 45 minutes just
pressure washing gallons of water into
the carpet in order to try and flush as
much mud out of it as possible
well not only that we had to flip it
over and spray out mud on the other side
and then we actually had to let it drain
overnight to try and dry out as much as
we could before we put it back in the
next day to then continue to clean it
inside the car so once the carpet's dry
we then place it back into the vehicle
and we use carpet soap you spray it onto
the carpet
and then i actually use the extractor to
add more water in order to create a
soapier solution and then you agitate it
using a brush that connects to a drill
to release some of the dirt and grime or
the stains that are contained within the
carpet fibers bring them to the top so
then you can suck it away with the
extractor
in the extractor we only use water if
you spray the soap onto the carpet and
if you only have water in your extractor
when you see through the head of the
extractor that there's no more foam
there's no more bubbles or soap that's
coming out of the carpet you know you've
not only removed the contaminants that
were in the carpet but also any residue
from a leftover soap
when we were cleaning the leather we had
to pressure wash the majority of the mud
away first in order to even reveal the
leather to follow a normal type of
detailing method there was too much mud
on the surface to really remove it in
any other way so that's not typically
how we would clean leather seats but
drastic cases call for drastic measures
we then used an all-purpose cleaner in a
tornado it's basically compressed air
that feeds into a reservoir that holds
an all-purpose cleaner and then it uses
that compressed air to pick up the
solution and blast it into the material
that you're trying to clean we'll use it
when we know that the leather has seen a
lot of age and we don't want to
potentially damage it further and then i
went ahead and used a leather brush in
order to agitate that further to remove
as much mud and sediment as possible
these would have to dry for another
couple days in a heated storage facility
with the exterior we went ahead and just
did a pretty basic wash so we had to
make sure that we just blew out all the
mud from all the cracks and crevices
there the foam cannon is my personal
favorite part when it comes to washing
the exterior of a vehicle foam and soap
is the same thing it's actually like
shaving cream you spray it onto your
hand and as you lather it up it becomes
more foamy it helps break down some of
the grime the grease the sediment on the
vehicle and then lifts it to the top and
that way as you're washing there's both
lubrication as well as cleaning
properties that help you remove the dirt
and grime as efficiently and safely as
possible
cleaning the windows most people ask
what solution you're using what window
cleaner are you using but in reality
it's the the type of tile that you use
and how many tiles you use and how clean
they are so windows are very prone to
streaking especially when they've been
splattered with mud like they were in
this vehicle
so to start out we just use your
standard shop towels in order to remove
the bulk of the grime and then we use
another type of towel that's called gsm
so it has a higher grams per square
meter of microfiber and all that means
is that there's more fibers on the towel
and the more grams per square meter the
fluffier the towel and the more
microfiber strands there are to wipe
away any of the streaks
they actually were able to get that car
running again though it still functions
but with a good conscious they can't
sell that car to another owner
when you finish it and you look back at
the result you know we we laugh because
it's it's almost like i don't know how
this i don't know how it came out so
well but somehow it does